there are new developments and still a
ton of misinformation so on this
Wednesday check-up coronavirus episode
two right off the bat I have to say
again we should not be panicking alert
not anxious is the mindset I want you to
take just like I said in the first
coronavirus video last week there's been
a ton of headlines with the w-h-o
declaring a global health emergency the
CDC declaring a national emergency here
in the United States but all of those
are not reasons to panic I'm gonna be
explaining what each of those things
mean what they mean for you
things you can do to keep yourself safe
and put this whole coronavirus thing
into perspective as to the way we see it
now and how the situation is gonna
expand and change today's date is
February 3rd 2020 the reason I tell you
that is because the numbers are gonna
change moving forward and I want you to
know when this video was filmed we're
also gonna learn more about this virus
we're gonna learn how it spreads we're
gonna learn more about its genetic
makeup how it came about so I want you
to be as up-to-date as possible
I may make another coronavirus video for
next week's Wednesday checkup we'll see
how that situation evolves let's start
off this episode by talking numbers over
20,000 individuals worldwide have been
infected with this novel coronavirus
there's been 436 deaths worldwide with
the huge majority of them being in China
there's only been a single death outside
of China that's been in the Philippines
in the u.s. currently we have 11 cases
no fatalities since we're talking about
numbers I thought it would be
interesting to mention there are still
60 million individuals on lockdown in
China this very moment because the
Chinese government is trying to do
anything and everything it can to limit
the spread of this virus next I thought
we'd move on to the designation that the
w-h-o released last week saying that
this is a global health emergency and
when they did this I saw a lot of tweets
come my way of people critiquing my
previous video where I said that we
should be alert not anxious and not
panic and say well how are you saying
this isn't a crisis if the w-h-o is
labeling this a global health emergency
let's explain what the w-h-o means when
they say something's of global health
emergency practically speaking this is
going to open up avenues for networks
communication between clinical sites
research sites lab sites it's gonna
unlock dollars that could be spent for
these networks on top of that w-h-o is
going to be able to hold countries
accountable for reporting accurate
numbers so we know what's going on
internationally we can monitor the
situation well it does not mean that
they labeled at a global health
emergency and we should panic in fact
it's the exact opposite
they're taking steps to prevent us from
panicking by making educated decisions
and unlocking much-needed dollars to
help combat the situation now moving on
to the designation by the CDC of a
national health emergency here in the
United States again this is not cause to
panic it's obviously a reason to be
alert not anxious I'm going to repeat
that throughout the video but the reason
they're doing this is because they're
taking extra precaution and steps to
make sure that the virus does not find
itself here in the US again the huge
majority of these cases the twenty
thousand cases are in China there's only
11 cases in the US and we want to keep
that number as low as possible
what is the CDC doing well first and
foremost we've increased screening to 20
airports we also decrease the amount of
flights coming from China to the US and
now if you're a foreign national meaning
that you're not a US citizen and you're
not a direct relative of a US citizen if
you're from China or you've recently
visited China within the last 14 days
you will not be allowed to visit the US
during this time on top of it if you are
a citizen and you're coming back from
the area in China known as the Hubei
Province apologize if I'm mispronouncing
that that's the area where the virus
first broke out Wu Han is the main city
there you're gonna be held in quarantine
for 14 days so if you're coming from
that city you're coming back to the US
and your citizen or you're a family
member of a citizen here 14 days
quarantine just to make sure you don't
have the virus because the worst thing
that could happen is if you come from
that area you don't know if you have the
virus yet you go into the public you get
a little sick you think it's a regular
cold but it's really this novel
coronavirus you can get a lot of people
sick very quickly it is quite infectious
much like the regular flu I'm going to
be talking about that a bit as an
interesting fact the last time we had
this type of quarantine period happen
1960s with the smallpox epidemic for
those of you who don't know we've
eradicated smallpox thanks to
vaccinations which is why I'm very Pro
vaccinations obviously not for just that
reason but it's an important thing to
know something else the CDC is doing is
it's working in partnership with the FDA
to accelerate the approval process for
the testing that's happening for the
corona virus which at this time can only
be done at CDC headquarters in Atlanta
the whole process really takes anywhere
from 24 to 36 hours which is quite a
long time hopefully they are able to
accelerate this approval process and get
that process down to somewhere like four
to six hours and get the test spread
outside of just the CDC lab that's the
goal it's a lot easier to test it in
regional Hospital sites than having to
ship the tests to CDC every single time
you may have seen some headlines that
call this corona virus outbreak an
epidemic those headlines are correct
some have said that it's gonna be a
pandemic you might be wondering what's
the difference well an epidemic is a
spike in cases in a given area a
pandemic is a worldwide spread affecting
many countries with large numbers of
people infected it has not yet been
ruled to be a pandemic by the World
Health Organization or pretty much any
health organization that being said it's
very possible that it may turn into a
pandemic but again these are just
definitions they don't really mean
anything for you and I on day to day
terms in fact what I take away from the
possibility of this becoming a pandemic
and I certainly hope that it doesn't
continue to spread is that the countries
that are going to be affected most by
this disproportionately are those that
are the low socio-economic countries
ones that don't have a modern health
care system you think about certain
countries in Africa India where there's
high rates of poverty you're gonna have
individuals that are going to be dying
from this simply because they don't have
access to supportive care you may
remember that in the previous video that
I did on this virus I said that there is
no treatment
well while there's no treatment we can
definitely give supportive care just
recently the NIH director came out and
said about 20% of these cases require
intensive care monitoring
is usually in the form of mechanical
ventilation and if you live in an area
where that's not available it's very
possible that one in five people will
continue losing their lives and
certainly low GDP countries will not be
able to build a thousand bed hospital in
the center of a city in ten days like
they just did in China in fact I believe
that Center did just open today and its
sole purpose is to help those who are
suffering with the corona virus now
let's move on to things that we've
learned about this virus that we didn't
know from the first video again this is
a lower respiratory tract type of virus
that your body really needs to fend off
on its own the primary symptoms are
fever cough and shortness of breath if
you're experiencing those and you've
recently visited China or you have some
relatives or friends that have visited
China you should right away call your
health provider let them know that
you're coming with these symptoms so
they can prepare the waiting area so as
to not get any extra people sick
especially those with compromised immune
systems new things that we've learned
first you may remember that I mentioned
something about asymptomatic spread of
this virus and it was something that we
were really concerned let me explain
that a bit further those who are
infected with the virus but are not
showing symptoms meaning that they don't
have a fever call for shortness of
breath they can technically spread the
virus we found out this to be true now
the cases where they have spread the
virus these asymptomatic individuals the
cases have been rather mild also when we
look back at the history of past
pandemics the main drivers of these
viruses have been those who have been
ill in fact this virus is quite similar
in the way that it spreads in the way
that it gets people sick to our current
influenza virus and I bring that up
specifically to put things into
perspective
there's so many people that are worried
about the corona virus here in the
United States there's 11 people with it
zero people have died just this flu
season there have been more than 19
million cases of denn flu Enza virus
there have been over a hundred eighty
thousand hospitalizations and over ten
thousand deaths the influenza virus is
what is a serious threat to our health
and I see many patients that have not
yet gotten their flu shot get your flu
shot because the influenza virus is a
real threat and it's imminent and it's
here now we're gonna talk about how
corona virus is gonna evolve and what
can happen
next steps but right now you can protect
yourself against influenza by getting
vaccinated I'll be saying the same thing
if we do create a vaccine in time for
the corona virus as well and if you're
interested in ways you can stay safe
whether you're traveling or not I gave
all those tips in my first video
definitely check that out another
interesting thing we've learned is that
this virus can spread through the
digestive tract meaning the fecal-oral
route so countries that have poor
sanitation they could be facing even a
bigger challenge and currently there is
no evidence that the corona virus the
specific novel coronavirus can affect
your pets and I say that because there's
been a ton of people ordering these face
masks for their poor pets thinking that
they're gonna protect them somehow with
these masks no you're not and the w-h-o
has been clear that there's been no
threat to your pets at home there
doesn't need a mask
speaking of face masks this has been a
major unintended consequence of all of
this news coverage and hype and
misinformation about this virus that
people have bought so many of these face
masks that they're running out of supply
for hospital systems look the reason we
need these surgical masks the
inexpensive ones that go around the
mouth and wrap around the ears is
because if someone is sick with the
corona virus it lends the common cold
it's good for patients to wear them so
that they don't get us sick it's meant
for those who are sick to not transmit
not for you to stay safe there's no
recommendation from any organization
that you at home need one of these masks
leave it to the professionals
and I've seen some absolutely crazy
Instagram posts of certain influencers
posing with some of these masks showing
how stylish they are this is medical
equipment the fact that we're having
shore jizz of it puts medical
professionals at risk and that's
absolutely crazy to me I want to share a
quick story of something my patient told
me just a couple of days ago that has me
concerned
so my patient who happens to be of Asian
descent told me that a couple of days
ago because they take the bus in
everyday from New Jersey to New York for
work people stopped sitting next to them
because they're worried about this
coronavirus because it comes from China
and that's just really disappointing
that type of xenophobia doesn't belong
here in the US we're better than that
there's only 11 cases here
the u.s. none in the New York New Jersey
area and forgetting that we should not
be xenophobic we should not be a racist
should not be labeling anyone that's
never ideal look you know I don't stand
for that and I hope that we can all do
better finally I want to give a huge
shout out to all the doctors health
professionals first responders that are
working on combating this novel
coronavirus out there there's actually
groups of researchers traveling from the
w-h-o to Wuhan China to help fight this
to learn more about it and we have to
give them a huge thank you in fact just
the other day we lost the first doctor
to this novel coronavirus in Wuhan China
and that's always unfortunate we as
healthcare providers put our lives on
the line every time something like this
happens I think that's really important
to say finally stay alert not anxious
don't allow these media entities that
put scary headlines out there to make
you panic if you want quality
information visit the CDC WH o NIH
websites or tune in and check out my
videos I'm going to be delivering
messages from those sources and giving
you the most up-to-date information
remember this video filmed February 3rd
2020 if you want to see my first video
on the corona virus click here and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]